مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياضه هي ابرز عناوينها
الشرطه السودانيه تستدعي متقاعديها لحمل
السلاح وفولكر يؤذن الموقف بين البرهان
والامم المتحده
سينطلق العراق نحو شراكه
10 دول تحشد طاقتها في طريق التنميه مشروع
اقليمي للتغيير للوجه الاقتصادي للشرق
الاوسط
الفضاء ريان وعلي يجريان تجارب علميه
مباشره مع طلاب المدارس في السعوديه
في الرابعه ايضا ما كان اول فيه فحوصات ما
قبل الزواج الامراض الوراثيه تؤرق الاسره
السعوديه الرابعه توثق معاناه احدى الاسر
ترقب لجوله حاسمه في الدوري السعودي نقاط
الفيحاء تفصيل الاتحاد عن اللقب والعالميه
الثانيه
دعت شرطه السودانيه متقاعديها للتسلح
لتامين الاحياء وبسط الامن في البلاد
وقالت الشرطه في بيان لها انها تطلب ممن
لديهم القدره التقدم لحمل السلاح في سبيل
زياده الرقعه الجغرافيه الامنه في البلاد
وكذلك لتامين الاحياء والمناطق الحيويه
والاسواق لبسط الامن والاستقرار
ميدانيا قال الجيش السوداني انه تمكن من
صد هجوم لقوات الدعم السريعه على مدينه
الفاشر في ديرفور بحسب ما افادت به مصادر
للعربيه اضافت المصادر نفسها ان الجيش فك
الحصار الذي فرضته قوات الدعم السريع على
الانجيل لمده اسبوع مضيحه بان الجيش تدخل
بالطيران الحربي لبسط سيطرته على المدينه
الواقعه وسط الاقليم
انضم الينا من الخرطوم المحلل السياسي
خالد الفكي سيد خالد مرحبا بك معنا اولا
لماذا يعني
اقدم الجيش وكذلك الشرطه على تقديم
الان او على مخاطبه المتقاعدين لحمل سلاح
حرب المدن حيث ان الان الدعم هو معروف
ينتشر بكثافه في العدد كبير من احياء
الخرطوم وربما القوات المسلحه لا تستطيع
استخدام الاسلحه الثقيله داخل الاحياء
وربما تؤدي الى مزيد من ثغور الضحايا ولكن
ايضا بالمقابل نجد ان هذه الدعوه ربما في
مخاطر على المدنيين في حسبان ان
المتقاعدين من منسوبي الجيش والقوات
المسلحه والذين اذا ذهبوا الى التسلح ربما
يكونهم باسلحه اقل من التي هي في حوزه
الدعم السريع المتواجد داخل الاحياء
فبالتالي اعتقد ان هذه معركه غير متقاطعه
وان كانت ستجد من حركه الدعم السريع
وتقدمه ولكن دون شركه سيكون يعني تاثيرات
سالبه على الحياه المدنيه المدنيين
والاحياء التي هي الان في قبضه وانتشار
الدعم السريع فبالتالي اعتقد ان هذا الامر
ينبغي ان يكون من خلال التنسيق وتركيبات
عاليه المستوى حتى يعني لا تقع الضحايا
يعني جديده وسط المدنيين لان الدعوه
لمحاوله تسليح المتقاعدين ربما يقود الى
فوضى يعني امريكا السلاح الى عدد كبير من
المدنيين مما يؤدي الى مواجهات يعني يعني
يخشى ان تؤدي الى يعني مزيد من من الضحايا
فبالتالي اعتقد انه لا بد من التركيبات
المحكمه لابد من التنسيق حتى لا تكون هناك
معارك بين المدنيين وبين الدعم السريع
الداخل الاحيائي ينبغي ان تكون هناك
ترتيبات عاليه المستوى وان تكون هناك
قيادات من الجيش والشرطه هي التي تقود
بعمليات الدعم
منسوبيه الدعم السريعه داخل الاحياء ولكنه
ترك الامر للمجانين المتقاعدين هذا سيؤدي
الى مزيد من الضحايا والى مزيد من الفوضى
يعني في الاحياء سيد خالد
نتابع حيث اكد مجلس السلم والامن
الافريقيه انه لا حل عسكري للازمه في
السودان وشددا على ضروره وقف القتال فورا
ودون شروط مسبقه واضاف مجلس السلم والامن
الافريقي ان القتال في السودان سببه
اختلاف الرؤى بشان الاتفاق الايطالي
الموقع في ديسمبر الماضي ونعيد التذكير
ايضا بازمه البرهان مع المبعوث الاممي حيث
اعلن الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
تجديد الثقه برئيس بعثه الامم المتحده
المتكامله لدعم الانتقال في السودان يوني
تايمز فولكس ردا على طلب رئيس مجلس سياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان باقاله فولكر
بسبب ما قال انه اصبح مصدرا انعكاسات
سلبيه عن الانطباع اتجاه الامم المتحده
كوتيريتش قال ان الامم المتحده مصدومه من
طلب الجيش السوداني تغييرا مبعوث الاممي
وكان رئيسه مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان طالب الامم المتحده
باستبدال رئيس بعثتها المتكامله لدعم
الانتقال في السودان
وقال انما قضاه على راس البعثه لا يساعد
في تنفيذ تفويض يونيتامس بصوره التي تسهم
بالوصول لعمليه انتقال ناجحه
في السودان الجيش يطالب الامم المتحده
باقاله مبعوثها الاممي فولكر بيرس الجيش
السوداني فولكرز شجع قائد قوات الدعم
السريع على التمرد فولكر بورس مارست تضليل
في تقاريره حول الاتفاق الايطالي وجود
فولكر بيرس لا يدعم المرحله الانتقاليه في
السودان عبد الفتاح البرهان نطلب اختيار
بديل ليبرس حفاظا على العلاقه بين الامم
المتحده والسودان
فولكا بيرس طرف الصراع في السودان يدركان
ان استمرار القتال لن يقود الى النتيجه
المرجوه
سيد خالد الفك المحلل السياسي معي ايضا من
الخرطوم
مدى وراء دعوه عبد الفتاح البرهان بابعاد
فولكر بيرتس من منصبه كمبعوث الامم
المتحده في السودان والى اي مدى الان موقف
الامم المتحده يمكن ان يؤزم الموقف بين
البرهان وبين المنظمه الدوليه
يبدو ان هذه ستكون المعركه جديده بين
الحكومه الراهنه وبين المجتمع الدولي
الامم المتحده بشكل خاص اعتقد يعني هذا
المبعوث الذي الان يطالب البرهان بابعاده
وهو ينفذ السياسه كليه ولا يعني وحتى اذا
ذهب يعني اوتي لشخص اخر اعتقد انه سيذهب
في ذات السياسه المتعلقه بما تعرف بسياسه
الانتقال الديمقراطي في السودان الذي
تنفذها البوميه
الخرقوم بالتالي اعت
قد ينبغي ان لا يكون الحديث عن الاشخاص
وانما يكون الحديث عن السياسات المتعلقه
بالانتقال ومحاوله وضعي روعه وحلول جديده
من قبل الحكومه البرهان فيما يتعلق بتعامل
الداسه العموميه في السودان مع اليات وطرق
التحول الديمقراطي ولكن انسداد شخص بشخص
اخر اعتقد انه يحل القضيه لان الامر هبوط
بسياسه هبوط بخطه مربوط فكره موضوعه من
قبل المتحده لاستكمال التحويل الديمقراطي
في السودان فاذا حتى اذا ذهبوا فولك
يعني جديد لن يذهب بافكار جديده ولكن
سياسه بذاته السياسه التي كان بها فوق
وبالتالي ينبغي ان البرهان وعلى الحكومه
السودانيه انتسب في مواضعي معالجات لاسيات
الكليه التي تتعامل بها الامم المتحده
فيما يتعلق بالتحويل الديمقراطي واجراءاته
وتطبيقه على وقع السودان بعيدا من اي
مزايد
برؤيه تقود الى ما يمكن ان يفضي الى حلول
الجديه ولكن هكذا اطلاق
مثل هذه التصريحات والمطالبات دون وضعي
روعه او دون اي حلول من قبل حكومه الب
رهان الازمه جديده ونخشى ان يؤدي ذلك الى
مزيد من العقوبات التي تلوح بها الامم
المتحده او تلوح بها الولايات المتحده
وتروح بها بعض الدول التي هي تقول ان كل
من يريد عرقله
المتوقفي سيواجه عقوبته للحكومه ان تكون
اكثر وعيا وتتراكا فانه ينبغي ان تتحدث عن
السياسات وليس عن الافراد الذين هم لا
ينفذون السياسات الامم المتحده اول خطه
الكليه المعروفه
يعني تمليك الشعب السوداني يعني وسائل
التحول الديمقراطي وتشكيل الحكومه المدنيه
شكرا جزيلا لك المحلل السياسي خالد
يحتضن العاصمه العراقيه بغداد مؤتمر وزراء
النقل لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ودول
الجوار العراق
واعلن مع بدء المؤتمر يطلق مشروع طريق
التنميه الاستراتيجي او ما يعرف بالقناه
الجافه الذي يمتد من البصره جنوب العراق
الى الحدود التركيه بطول نحو الفكم وينتظر
ان يشكل طريق التنميه مسارا حيويا مهما
لجميع بلدان المنطقه
بهذا المشروع الواعد
سينطلق العراق نحو شراكه اقتصاديه معكم
تجعل بلداننا مصدرا للصناعات الحديثه
والبضاعه
معتمدين في كل هذا على الممرات متعدده
الوسائط
واكثر من
1200 كيلو متر من السكك الحديديه
وتشغيلها البيني المشترك
ومثلها الطرق السريعه التي ستسر عمليه نقل
البضاعه
والوظائف التي ستخلقها هذه الحزمه من
المشاريع
وكل هذا سيكون بصمه ايجابيه تنقل كل شعوب
المنطقه الى مرحله غير مسبوقه من التواصل
والتكامل
وهو ما يعني الاستقرار
والقدره على مواجهه ناجحه للتحديات وزير
النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه السعودي المهندس
صالح الجاسر ركض خلال مؤتمر طريق التنميه
في بغداد ان العلاقات بين السعوديه
والعراق تشهد نموا في العديد من المشاريع
المشتركه مشيرا في الوقت ذاته ان المستقبل
سيكون واعدا
حقيقه العلاقات بين البلدين الشقيقين هي
علاقات قويه
وراسخه وتشهد العديد من مشاريع التعاون
قبل يومين انعقد مجلس التلسيق السعودي
العراقي في مدينه جده وحضره مجموعه من
وزراء البلدين الشقيقين وهذا المجلس يعني
انتج العدد من البرامج
والمشاريع التعاون سواء افتتاح منفذ جديده
عرعر او اطلاق الرحلات الجويه او تعاون في
مجال التعليم ومجال الاستثمار والربط
الكهرباء وغيره من مشاريع الخير والبركه
والنماء للبلدين الشقيقين وان شاء الله
المستقبل واعد لمزيد من المشاريع التي
تنعكس على الشعبين الشقيقين
الرابعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل حرب
السعوديه على المخدرات تتواصل ضبطيات
بالملايين خلال شهر مايو الجري
اهلا بكم يوم سادس يقضيه رائد الفضاء
السعوديان ريان وعلي الجني في المحطه
الدوليه وجراء قبل ساعه قليله اتصال مرئي
بين الرائدين وعدد من طلاب المدارس في
السعوديه اجرت فيه الرائدان تجربه حول
انتشار الالوان السائله في الفضاء
مستعدين نبدا
زي ما انتم شايفين اول خطوه السائل بعدين
الالوان
بعدها راح نضيف الصابون الصابون زي ما
انتم عارفين عنده جزء قطبي يحب المويه
وجزء غير قطبي يطرز المويه
فنتوقع حسب ما صارت على الارض انه راح
تتكون اشكال كذا غريبه
من الالوان لكن ما نعرف هنا في انعدام
الجاذبيه ايش ممكن حيحصل يلا نشوف يلا بسم
الله ثلاثه اثنين واحد
على جلسه المعايشه التي نفذتها مؤسسه
الملك عبد العزيز موهبه لطلابها مع رائدى
الفضاء ريان وعلي متابعه
مئات الطلاب والطالبات هنا في موهبه
سينفذون تجربه علميه مع راعيدي الفضاء
ريان وعلي ضمن البحوث العلميه في مجال
الفضاء الدكتور باسل السدحان وهنائب
الامين العام لخدمات الموهوبين اليوم لو
نتكلم عن التجربه التي سوف ينفذها الطلاب
والطالبات في موهبه ما راعيدي الفضاء الان
بشكل مباشر نعم تم تنفيذ اليوم التجربه
الانتشار السوائل الوان السائله في الارض
تحت الجاذبيه الطبيعيه وتم تنفيذها قبل
قليل من الرائديه الفضاء تحت الجاذبيه
الصغرى او انعدام الجاذبيه الهدف التفريق
بين التجربه في ظل الظروف الطبيعيه
للجاذبيه وفي الفضاء هذا طبعا تجربه اليوم
يشارك فيها اليوم وغدا وبعد حوالي 1000
طالب من المدارس الشركه في موهبه واليوم
هنا في الرياض اكثر من 60 طالب من المرحله
الابتدائيه موهبه تهتم باعداد جيل الفضاء
للمشاركه في
رؤيه المملكه عشرين ثلاثين عندما يكبرها
هؤلاء الطلاب باذن الله شكرا لك دكتور اذا
في هذه اللحظات ايضا ينفذ رائدي الفضاء
ريان وعلي تجاربهم البحثيه العلميه ما عدد
كبير من الطلاب في اكثر من 45 موقعا لحظات
مباشره
وتطرح الاسئله ايضا في هذه اللحظات من قبل
هؤلاء الطلاب والطالبات سواء في موهبه او
باقي المواقع التي المحدده في كافه مناطق
السعوديه لقناه العربيه هاني الصفيان
الرياض
الفرصه جميله لنا على وزميلاتي
التحدث مع استاذه علي القرني واستاذه
ريالي البرناوي وهم في الفضاء اود يوما من
ايام ان اكون مكانهم اليوم سوينا تجربه
الالوان السائله
هي تجربه تهدف يعني زياده المعرفه حول حول
يعني التوتر سطحي
والفرق بين التجربه في الفضاء والارض
بصراحه مره فخوره بريانا
ارفعوا راس السعوديين والعرب والمسلمين
كلهم فخر واحس انه السرور ونجاح بانهم
لانهم هم فخر العرب اليوم شعوري مبسوط مره
يعني تجارب حلوه حطوا لنا اغراض حنا نسوي
فيها ومجموعات وعلمونا كيف نشترك مع بعض
اليوم كانت ممتعه صدقيه لاني انا كلمت
راعينا برنامج على القرني وتعلمت تجربه
انتشار الالوان السائله
وصراحه كانت الرحله طويله لكن تستحق هذه
الرحله كامله ادعي الله الرائدين الفضاء
ريان ريان ريان وعلي انه ما ينزلون
بالسلامه
ويستكشفون اشياء جديده وانام باذن الله
راح اصير مثلهم واليوم قد استمتعنا معهم
بعمل تجربه انتشار الالوان
مكالمه رواد الفضاء واسئله واسئله تجاوب
عنها
نجاوب عنها وجدا جميل لهذا اليوم وكان
افضل افضل يوم لديك
ضغطيات بالملايين بين يوم واخر تشهدها
منافذ السعوديه اخرها ضبط نحو نصف مليون
حبه كبتاجون في ميناء ضبا في تبوك خلال
شهر مايو ايضا ضبطت الحمله التي تنفذها
وزاره الداخليه ومديريه مكافحه المخدرات
ملايين الحبات من الكبتاجون واطنان من
الحشيش
فضلا عن ضبط عدد من المروجين لماده الشكوى
وزير الداخليه السعوديه الامير عبد العزيز
بن سعود بن نايف اكد قبل ايام ان الحمله
لن تتوقف حتى تحقيق كامل اهدافها
ونتوقف الان مع ابرز ضبطيات المخدرات التي
شهدها شهر مايو جاري في عدد من المنافذ
والمدن السعودي
[موسيقى]
في استديوهاتنا من الرياض ينضم الينا سفير
المشروع السعودي للوقايه من المخدرات
نبراز الفنان فايز المالكي يا علي خالد
يعطيك العافيه الله يبقيك وانا شاكر تحت
الفرصه لي في قناه العربيه القناه الام
اللي تقدم كل شيء مصداقيه ويا رب اكون ضيف
خفيف عليكم دائما ضيف الله يوفقك دايما
ابو راكان يبرز اسمك واحد من اهم الرواد
والمؤثرين والبارزين في المشاريع الخيريه
والانسانيه وما انطلاق الحمله كان لك ايضا
فيديو كان مؤثر تناقلته يمكن كل المواقع
كل المساحات كل الوكالات الانباء ظهرت
فيها بشكل مختلف ابو راكان يعني قدمت
رساله كانت مؤثره في في في نبره صوتك في
في طريقه عرضك ايضا وسط اكوام من المخدرات
اللي شفناها والحبوب
يمكن من الحملات المكافحه المخدرات لكن
ليش ظهرت بهذه الصوره وش اللي شفته في هذه
الحمله مختلف عن حمله سابقة شارك فيها
والله خالد وانا اخوك اللي صورته ثمانيه
مليون و250 الف حبه يعني اعتمدوا 50 مليون
هذا
وانتشرت على الرياض دمرت الرياض كلها يا
اخي انا عندي اطفال عندي بنات عندي اقارب
عندي احبه لو طاحت فيهم الحبوب هذي دمرت
مستقبلهم انتم قبل شوي تعرضون ما شاء الله
تبارك الله نشر مع رواد الفضاء حنا واصلين
الفضاء ما شاء الله تبارك الله يتكلمون
انه على الوان تكلمنا على رواد الفضاء
اللي موجودين بالله لو وصل لها الاطفال
لها النشر اليوم التطبيقات منتشره اليوم
الاماكن التي توصلكم تجيكم من امريكا تجي
لحد بيتك فبالتالي احنا شعب مستهدف دليفري
اي طبعا احنا شفت انا شفت شيء الحقيقه من
خلال قناتكم اوجه شكر لوزير الداخليه
والرجال مكافحه والجمارك نشوف اشياء عظيمه
جدا تقبض عليها انا سته كيلو يقول لي
الضابط السته الكيلو هذا الشبوب لو توزعت
على الرياض دمرتها على الرياض اذا كان
الوصل
سته كيلو ويضاف عليها المكونات
الشباب والزياره الواحده تخليك تدمن يعني
ما في تراجع مو تقول والله بجرب سيجاره
وبعدين لا خلاص من اول مره من اول مره
فبالتالي لازم نخاف لازم نتحمس التلقائيه
والتقليديه العاديه اللي كنا اول شيء
التقدير المخدرات هذاك المخدرات ضايعه ما
عاد تنفع الان انت تقصد الرسائل التوعويه
الان اذا ما تقول هذه يا جماعه شوفوا
بعينكم شوفوا بام عينكم هذا المخدرات هذا
الهلاك هذا الضياع هذا
ينفع انا ممكن اجي اصوره الان المخدرات
هذا شكرا لك ما احد لكن اعتقد انه بعد
اللي صورناه وهذا ما هو تقليل في جوده
الاخرين لكن الرساله وصلت
في شيء غلط جدا فبالتالي الله يحفظها
المقطع هذا مشاهداته فوق 350 مليون هذا بس
في الحسابات اللي انا اتابعها
كثير خالد كثير انه انا عندي واحد من
عيالي بس يا اخي انا خايف ابلغ ثم يمسكونه
وننفضح لا ما في فضيحه اليوم وزاره
الداخليه وعلى الامير عبد العزيز بن سعود
بن نايف والعاملين في مكافحه المخدرات وفي
مستشفى الامل للوقايه ولا العلاج المدمنين
ترى سريه تامه اذا حسيت ان اخوك مدمن اذا
الزوجه مدمنه اذا الزوج مدمنه اذا اي واحد
يا اخي يبلغ فيه ترى يمسكونه ويعالجونه
ويخاطبون مقر عملاء انه في مهمه من خلال
وزاره الداخليه ما في اي فضائح سريه تامه
لكن احنا نسكت ليش نسكت انت اذا سكت
لكن ممكن يصير قتل في بيتك واخر شيء شفناه
انت عارف انه القضايا اللي قتال الشبه هذا
كل يوم يقتل الاثنين ثلاثه لان ما عندي
خلاص ما عندي اي ما عنده اي تفكير انه
يرتك باي جريمه ويسوي اي شيء لانه يمشي
على الارض فساد خلاص ما في خوف ما في
احساس بالمسؤوليه يا اخي بعضهم صار [__]
بعضهم قتلوا امه بعضهم قتل ابوه بعضهم
يجيب الرجال بيت العياله المساله كبرت جدا
وش اللي ينقص طيب في وجهه نظرك انت ابو
راكان هذه الحمله حتى تؤدي غرضها بشكل
مطلوب في جهد كبير يبذل ونشوف انه
المملكه من خلال هالجنه والمكلف والحمله
ايضا اشبه بالحرب اللي تقيمها على
المخدرات في كل شارع نشوف يعني نقاط تفتيش
وغيرها والله يعطيهم العافيه لكن انت في
وجهه نظرك حتى تحقق هذه الحمله اهدافها في
شيء ناقص في شيء مطلوب اول شيء الشكل سموه
الامير محمد بن سلمان والعاد على تبني
هالح العظيمه والشكر موصول لكل وزاره
الداخلي وعلى راسي وزير الداخليه لكن
خلونا نبعد عن الشيء التقليدي
التقليدي يا سيدي انه خلونا نصور انا طلب
اوجه الداخليه اترك الفائز المالكيري يصور
لا تقول الكلمه هذه حساسه لا المشهد هذا
المخدرات وين بعد تبي انا اعتقد انه رجال
الجمارك ورجال مخدرات في كل المنافذ عندنا
يمكن 14 منفذ وعندنا المواني ترى في كل
يوم ضبطيه وكل يوم يمسكون بلاوي الدنيا
فبالتالي خلونا نصور خلونا نروح على
الشباب والشابات خلونا العالم ما ينفع يا
جماعه امسك جوالي المخدرات هذاك هذا
وارميه هناك وفترتي طال عمرك
الشبو يا اخي انت ترى على فكره الناس
تتوقعون ان موقع السعوديه فقط احنا شايفين
بعد لكن الحمد لله احنا ابتدينا من حيث
الاخرين الحرب عليها اليوم حتى الشوارع
خفت انا مفحطين واللي يجيك ماشي 200 يمشي
في الشارع ما تشوفه اليوم في ضبط واتمنى
الحمله مو بس شهر شهرين ثلاثه اتمنى على
مدار الايام على مدار السنين منظف بلدنا
ونحفظ شبابنا تطالب انه تفتح الابواب لكم
طبعا
مثل ما شفنا التفاعل مثلا من خلال فايز
المالكي يعني في الحمله هذه وش الدور اللي
ترى انه يمكن ان ينعكس بشكل افضل من خلال
تواجد
التواصل الاجتماعي
سيدي الفاضل المشاهير يتابعون ملايين سواء
صغيره وكبير ام واب واخ وطفل كله كل واحد
له جمهوره وناسه
ومحبينه فبالتالي لو كل مشهور اعطيه
الفرصه ترى على فكره بعض المشاريع يقول لك
انا يا اخي ما طلبوني انا رحت ترى انا جيت
مكافحه المخدرات
نبراسي
ممكن
انت ناشط اجتماعي وعندك عندك عدد كبير
متابعين شرف
يا جماعه انا بصور هذا فايز المالكي صور
هذا الزعاق صور روح بادر يا اخي بادر
خلاها زكاه شهرتك
فبالتالي لازم تلاحظون وين يسارون وين
يروحون وين يجون وين يقعدون فيني براس في
مختصين كبير جدا
اخصائيين نفسيين ممكن يقول لك اذا ولدك
والله يقعد في غرفه بالعالم اذا ولدك
متعاطي ما فيها شيء ما فيها شيء
يعطيك ربي خالد
وجزاك الله خير على كل ما تكون فيه بعيدا
عن قصه المخدرات
يقولون نجيب العلم والله تقدر تقول ميسي
جاي للهلال
[ضحك]
انا ما ادري انا
مره يعني موجوده ترى هذا الرجل الالي اللي
في الجهاز
شكرا جزيلا شكرا لله الله يعطيكم العافيه
السفير المشروع السعودي للوقايه من
المخدرات
يعطيك العافيه
الامراض الوراثيه
والرابعه توثق معاناه تحت الاسر
شرطه السودانيه تستدعي متقاعديها لحمل
سلاح فولكر يوازيم الموقف بين البرهان
والامم المتحده بهذا المشروع الواعد
سينطلق العراق نحو شراكه اقتصادي عشر دول
تحشد طاقاتها في طريق التنميه مشروع
اقليمي لتغيير الوجه الاقتصادي للشرق
الاوسط
علميه مباشره مع طلاب المدارس في السعوديه
ما كان اول في والامراض الوراثيه تؤرق
الاسره السعوديه الرابعه توثق معاناه احدى
الاسر
ترقب لجوله حاسمه في الدوري السعودي نقاط
الفيحاء تفصيل الاتحاد عن اللقب والعالميه
اهلا بكم فحص الزواج احد اهم الاسباب
الوقائيه من امراض وراثيه عديده الا ان
البعض لا يدرك اهميه اخذ نتائج الفحص
بجديه النتيجه ابناء مصابون بمرض او امراض
وراثيه العربيه التقت احد المواطنين في
شرق السعوديه عناء وما زال يعاني من قرار
زواجه بدون فحص
[موسيقى]
علي القريش الذي تزوج في نهايه السبعينات
لم يدرك بان اول ابنائه سيكون مصابا بمرض
فقر الدم المنجلي بسبب غياب فحص ما قبل
الزواج انذاك رحله من المعاناه عاشها
الابن مع المرض الذي اثر على طفولته
ومراهقته في السابق يعني ما كان اول فيه
فحوصات ما قبل الزواج يعني قديما ما كان
في الامور هذه موجوده
بكون ان يعني الطب الان يعني
طور فاشوف ما شاء الله الان يعني الفحوصات
هذه ما قبل الزواج هذه قاعده تسوي حلول
وتسوي حد من
الامراض هذه الوراثيه كنت اشوف كل الاطفال
يزاولوا كامل
متعتهم في المكان ده ما عاده انا يعني كان
ابغى اسبح بحر ممنوع ابغى اسبح في بركه
ممنوع ابغى ازاول الشغله الفلانيه ممنوع
كلها كانت ممنوعه
خوفا على صحتي يعني احمد احد المصابين
بمرضه فقر الدم المنجلي فضلا الالتزام
بفحصه ما قبل الزواج والارتباط بفتاه
سليمه لضمان انجاب ابناء اصحاء قررت ان
انا اتزوج واخذ انسانه سليمه ما تعاني من
هذا المرض
عشان ننجب هذه الاولاد سليمين والحمد لله
رب العالمين وهذا من فضل الله سبحانه
وتعالى ينتشر في السعوديه ما يقربوا من
235 مركزا معتمدا للفحص الطبي قبل الزواج
في منشاه القطعين الحكومي والخاص بحسب
موقع وزاره الصحه والتي تقدم الفحص الطبي
للمقبلين على الزواج وتقديم الاستشارات
الطبيه لغير المطابقين تجنبا لتكوين اسره
غير سليمه صحيا في عندنا الفحص عن الامراض
الوراثيه وتشمل امراض فقر الدم المنجلي او
السيكل سيل وامراض الثلاثين بالنسبه الى
الجانب الثاني هي الكشف عن الامراض
المعديه وتشمل التهاب الفيروسات الكبد نوع
باء جيم بالاضافه الى فيروس نقص المناعه
المكتسب والذي يؤدي الى مرض الايدز بعض
المضاعفات تكون اكثر شيوعا في الاعمار
الصغيره وبعض المضاعفات تكون اكثر شيوعا
في حال التقدم التقدم بالسن لكن كل الفئات
العمريه معرضه لمضاعفات المرض من القطيف
علي اللغبي العربيه
ومعنا في استديوهات هنا من الرياضه
الدكتور ماجد الفاضل نائب المدير التنفيذي
لمركز الملك عبد الله العالمي للابحاث
الطبيه حياك الله دكتور سعداء بوجودك معنا
انا اكثر والله شرفني ذلك دكتور اولا هل
الفحص فحص ما قبل الزواج يعني
يمنع جميع الامراض الوراثيه حاليا الاجابه
لا فحص ما قبل الزواج يمنع عن الانيميا
المنجليه وانيميا البحر المتوسط حاليا فقط
لكن في توجه كبير ان شاء الله من قطاعات
يعني كثيره انه نوسع من الفحص
الوراثي قبل الزواج ليشمل اكثر الامراض
المعروفه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه باي
قدر ترى ان هناك وعي عند الناس اليوم يعني
في اهميه الفحص ما قبل الزواج
بدءا من من من توقيت اشتراطه وحتى اليوم
برايك دكتور سؤال ممتاز جدا
الوعي صراحه تحسن بشكل كبير كبير جدا
يعني في دراسه قبل فتره عملت عن مدى الوعي
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه عن فحص ما
قبل الزواج لقينا في تحسن بنسبه 50% او
الباحثين اللي عملوا هذا هذه
المقاله وجدوا انه 50% في تحسن وهذا شيء
طيب لكن حنا نامل انه يكون من تسعين الى
مئه بالمئه
ممكن يعني عده عوامل كثيره منها يعني يمكن
نحتاج اكثر حملات توعويه حملات ارشاديه
نحتاج اكثر انواع عيال الناس انه عن
الامراض الوراثيه وعن الجينات وما هي
الجينات في كثير يعني حتى من المتعلمين ما
يفهم وش معنى العلم حقنا الى الان هل ما
زالت في
في يعني حالات رصدتوها فيها اصرار من
الطرفين او من طرف واحد على اكمال الزواج
بالرغم من وجود نتائج ايجابيه
هي نتائج ايجابيه تصير للفحص ما قبل
الزواج عن احتماليه لامراض وثائق وراثيه
يعني يمكن ان تتعرض لها العائله طبعا اذا
كان
الخطيب والخطيب حاملين لنفس الجين في نسبه
25% في كل حمل انه يكون الطفل مصاب و75%
انه يكون الطفل سليم فهذه النسبه الاعلى
انه يكون سليم بس لسه في 25% انه يكون
الطفل مصاب
فوجدنا بعضهم
يعني يغامروا ويصر على الاقبال على الزواج
رغما لانهم حاملين للمرض لعوامل كثيره
منها اجتماعيه ومنها اشياء اخرى على الرغم
من انهم عارفين انه راح
يرزقوا بمولود ممكن يكون مصاب بمرض وراثي
وبياثر على
وشفنا نماذج كثيره يعني يمكن الناس
ندمت انها لم يعني تلتزم بنتائج الفحص
مثلا يعني صحيح صحيح مصرين في ناس مصرين
طب هذا ما هو يعتبر عيب اصلا في في او
مشكله في مساله الفحص الوراثي يعني انا
ارى انه مثلا يجب ان يكون الامر حازم في
هذه يجب ان يمنع الطرفين من الزواج بسبب
هذه النتائج لانه الخساره ستكون مؤلمه على
الاسره وعلى المجتمع وعلى يعني الكل يعني
في هذه الحاله سيكون شريك في هذه الماسه
سؤال ممتاز جدا صراحه لكن حنا كاطباء او
او حتى المشرعين ما نقدر نمنع بشكل تام
لعوامل اجتماعيه وعوامل اخلاقيه يعني احنا
اذا راينا من الجانب العلمي فقط ممكن لازم
نكون حازمين لكن لما نكون نراها من الجانب
الاجتماعي فمثلا هذه الزوجه
والزوج لو لو منعتهم يمكن ما تتزوج مره
اخرى فاهم علي في حيزيد مستوى العنوسه في
المجتمع فهذه الاشياء الاجتماعيه مهمه جدا
وايضا الاشياء الاخلاقيه يعني حنا
نسميه سكرينج يعني
فحص مسحي لانسان طبيعي فهذا لازم يكون
اختياري كليا ما يكون شيء اجباري فمن
اخلاقيات الطب انه لازم يكون اختياري وليس
اجباري كيف يتم التعامل في مثل هذه الحاله
دكتور ماجد التوعيه اهم شيء التوعيه
التوعيه والارشاد وش تقولون لهم يعني
نشرح لهم ونجيب لهم يعني قصص حيه وبعض
الاحيان ممكن
نوريهم اذا كان فيه عائله متعاونا نجيب
الطفل المصاب ونوريهم ونشرح لهم ونقول لهم
وايضا نعرض عليهم اللي هو الوقايه بحيث
انه نفحص فحص الجيني ونحدد الطفره وبعدين
نعمل الوقايه اللي هي الوقايه عن طريقتين
اللي هي السائل الامنيوسي ناخذ عينه من
يوسي ونشيك على نفس الطفره اللي لقيناها
عند
اللي هم الخطيبين اذا الطفل سليم اذا مصاب
يوجد قبل نفر يروح قبل نفخ الروح اللي قبل
19 اسبوع من الحمل والطريقه الاخرى اللي
هي الفحص الوراثي قبل الغراس او اطفال
الانابيب في فرق بيننا وبين دول حولنا في
منسوب او مستوى الوعي او في دول اخرى
متقدمه بالفحص الوراثي والالتزام بنتائجه
احنا نعتبر من يعني من اعلى الدول في فحص
الوراثي والجيني والتقدم في الامور هذه
والحمد لله يعني حاليا
مدى وعي الناس يقارن الدول الاوروبيه
والدول يعني شمال امريكا والدول الاخرى
يعني الوعي في هذه الامور متقارب جدا حتى
في الدول اللي سبقتنا في هذا المجال نشكرك
شك ر جزيلا على هذه الافاده الدكتور ماجد
الفاضل نائب المدير التنفيذي لمركز الملك
عبدالله العالمين للابحاث الطبيه انا اكثر
وشكرا جزيلا تشرفت بلقائكم تسلم قبل
الانتقال
وفي جازان غربيه السعوديه يعد موسم زراعه
الحبوب والمحاصيل الزراعيه مصدرا اساسيا
يغذي الاسواق الزراعيه من ابرز المنتجات
التي يحصدها المزارعون الذره الصفراء
والدخن والشعير والبقوليات وتمثل هذه
الفتره من الانتاج الزراعي اهميه كبيره
نظيره زياده الحالات المطريه او الحاله
المطريه في المنطقه خاصه في المناطق
الجبليه التي تتوافق مع موسم الحصاد
والمحاصيل الاخرى
من فيفا كما نشاهد الان هذه المناظر يعني
من جبال فيفا في جيزان ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه اسامه القاسم حياك الله اسامه
اهلا وسهلا خالد تحيه طيبه عليكم لجميع
مشاهدينا العربيه نعم هذه الصوره امامكم
من جبال فيفا جنوب السعوديه في الايام
الماضيه شهدت فيفا والمناطق الجبليه بشكل
عام هطوله امطار غزيره هي اليوم تدعوهم
الى ان يقوموا بزراعه هذه الاراضي
الموجوده والمدرجات الزراعيه بالحبوب
وايضا الاشياء التي تشتهر بها المناطق
الجبليه كونها تكون بارده مما يعني ان
هناك بعض الحبوب التي تكون مهياه في هذه
الفتره طبعا نتحدث اليوم عن الكثير من
المنتجات الزراعيه عن الكثير من المحاصيل
الذره الشعير وايضا الدخن والبر والكثير
من البقوليات يتم زراعتها في المناطق
الجبليه هي تحتاج هطول امطار كثيره وتحتاج
ايضا الى منطقه بارده او على اقل تقدير
معتدله لكي تكون يعني مهيئه لان تكون
بيكون موسم حصادها قريب جدا ايضا هي حالها
مثل حال البنهي فقط في المناطق الجبليه
نتحدث اليوم هنا من جبال فيفا وهم يبداون
هذه الايام زراعه هذه الاراضي ليغذي السوق
ايضا في المنتجات الزراعيه وايضا ليغطوا
احتياجاتهم الشخصيه من خلال هذه الارض
التي يزرعونها نرى الان عمليه الزراعه
التقليديه هنا في جبال فيفا جنوب السعوديه
اغلب المناطق الجبليه هنا ما زالوا
يعتمدون على الزراعه التقليديه ويعتمدون
ايضا على السماد الطبيعيه يعتمدون على
الكثير من الاشياء التقليديه التي تجعلهم
اليوم امام محل كبير جدا من الاهتمام بهذه
المناطق هم اليوم يقولون هذه المناطق
اتهماما كبيرا كونهم تعد من تراثهم وايضا
موروثين نتحدث اليوم من هذه المزارع هذه
المزرعه وايضا هنا البيوت الموجوده عمرها
اكثر من 500 عام نتحدث عن ارث عظيم
وتاريخي كبير جدا وهذه المناظر امامنا
اغلب المدرجات الزراعيه اليوم تقريبا
ممتلئه بالاشجار والمسطحات الخضراء ونتحدث
ايضا عن انهم بداوا اليوم تقريبا اقتربت
نهايه فتره الزراعه باقي على موسم الحصاد
تقريبا من شهرين الى ثلاثه اشهر اذا كانت
الاجواس ستستمر بهذه الديمومه على مستوى
الامطار طبعا نتحدث انه هذه السنه خالد من
اكثر السنوات التي شهدت هطول امطار غزيره
قبل موسم الزراعه نهيك الان عن موسم
الزراعه الذي سيشهد ايضا هطول امطار كثيره
حسب ايضا التنبيهات الحاصله من المركز
الوطني الارصاد وايضا التوقعات
المزارعين هنا يعرفون متى تقريبا تكون
موسم الزراعه
نعم انا الان ساخذه باللقاء خالد
الزراعه اليوم في فيفا
عم صديق اليوم احنا نتكلم ما هي الاشياء
التي تزرعونها اليوم تقريبا متى نتحدث عن
موسم الحصاد ايضا ما هي اغلب المشاكل التي
تواجهكم اليوم هنا في الزراعه هنا في
الجبال كونكم ايضا ما زلتم تعتمدون ايضا
على الزراعه التقليديه حياكم الله وبياك
وحيا الله قناه العربيه واهلا وسهلا يزرع
في فيفا كثيرا من الحبوب مثل الذره والغرب
والدخن
والزعر والقطن والكناب والذره
وكثيرا بعض الحبوب تزرع في جبال هيفاء
طبعا هذا هو موسم الصراع نحن الان في
مواسم الزراعه وسيتم حصادها بعد ثلاثه
شهور تقريبا
تقريبا بعد ثلاثه اشهر حيث يتم حصادها
باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى بالنسبه للمنطقه
الجبليه تعتمد على المياه في كثير من
تعتمد على المياه في كثيرا من الصراعات
الهوا جو عندنا بارد ونعتمد على امطار
السماء طبعا
نجتهد في احياء هذا الموروث ونجتهر في
يحيى هذا الارض ارض الاباء والاجداد يجب
ان نهتم بها ونعلمها لاجيالنا في المستقبل
وكذلك لنسد بعض حاجتنا من المنتوجات
البلديه الان ما ينتجه البلد لو جيت وتذوق
منتجات البلد او اللي نشتريه من السوق
تعرف الفرق
مثل ما قلت لك حنا نحيي هذا البلد
والمحافظه عليها وننقلها للاجيال
وبارك الله فيكم وشكرا لكم اخي العزيز
شكرا نعم صديق اذا انا اتحدث اليوم خالد
حدثني عن صديق عمار المواجهه التي او
المشاكل التي تواجههم اليوم هنا في
الزراعه تقريبا القرده قرده البابون هي
تاخذ معظم المحاصيل الزراعيه ايضا بعض
المبيدات التي قد تسبب في جعل هذه
المحاصيل الزراعيه مهدده بانها تقل على
مستوى الحصاد الطبيعي لا هي هنا تحتاج فقط
الى المياه والبروده وهذا ما تمتاز به
المناطق الجبين يتحدث اليوم ايضا عن
الكثير من المناطق التي ما زالت زراعه هنا
قله كبيره جدا في عدد المزارع التي تستمر
في الانتاج ولكن ايضا هذه الزراعه
التقليديه شكرا من فيفا في جيزان مراسل
العربيه اسامه القاسم العناوي
الشرطه السودانيه تستدعي المتقاعدين لحمل
السلاح وفول كاريو الزمو الموقف بين
البرهان والامم المتحده
دول تحشد طاقاتها في طريق التنميه مشروع
اقليم او مشروع اقليمي لتغيير الوجه
الاقتصادي للشرق الاوسط
الفضاء علي وريان يجريان التجارب علميه
مباشره مع طلاب المدارس في السعوديه
الامراض الوراثيه تؤرق الاسره السعوديه
والرابعه توثق معاناه احدى الاسر
وترقب لاثاره وجوله حاسمه في الدوري
السعودي نقاط الفيحاء تفصل الاتحاد عن
اللقب والعالميه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات